[Music]
[Music]
almost three years ago now some clever
people in the community noticed some
small owl statues scattered around the
roosevelt island mission
after finding them all and then brute
forcing a number of combinations they
finally managed to unlock one of the
game's secrets
a hidden room was discovered it was a
crudely dug-out bunker underground
containing a few fire pits and a much
larger owl statue
where it starts to get interesting is
when you salute the owl the following
message is played
the gears are turning the plan's in
motion
we'll have to scatter to avoid detection
this may be the last meeting of the
morovian society we'll feel the sight
until another who knows the rituals can
reopen it
when i first saw this my mind went
straight to bohemian grove which is a
gentleman's club that hosts the
gathering once a year composed of some
of the most prominent men in the world
business leaders government officials
former u.s presidents people of power
they meet up at a large camp in
california for two weeks of heavy
drinking super secret talks and strange
rituals
the bohemian grove ceremony cremation of
care is where members wear costumes and
perform a dramatic production before a
40-foot owl shrine
their purpose is to escape the frontier
culture or uncivilized interests of
common men
this club is so secretive that naturally
it has become a hotbed for conspiracy
theories over the years
so what does this have to do with the
division
well we've known for a while now that
there is a much larger power at play a
group of ties to the government that has
employed the black tusk they were also
the ones who had prison alice put in
power and were even responsible for
assisting in pushing dr gordon amherst
in the right direction when he was
creating the smallpox virus that started
it all
perhaps this is the place where it all
started
unfortunately i don't think this is
quite right firstly the cave looks a
little hastily dug out not something the
elites of society would have had built
it looks relatively new
also more importantly with subtitles
turned on we can see that it was an
outcast that was talking and the
outcasts didn't come to be until well
after the virus was released
so maybe this is a collection of the
more prominent members of outcasts who
were locked up on roosevelt island and
this was their place of planning for how
they were going to get back at society
for having them trapped in there left to
die
this could talk to the fact that we
haven't seen the last of the outcasts
perhaps emeline shaw was just put in
place as the leader when really there
was something much larger at play
pulling his strings
regardless i'm still not sure what the
significance of the morovian society is
although spelt slightly differently it's
quite close to the moravian church
this could be spelt differently for
copyright reasons like we've seen with a
number of other organizations in the
division story but what does a
protestant church have to do with the
outcasts
to add further confusion and questions
bohemia and moravia are neighboring
locations in the czech republic perhaps
there is something there to look into
as i said this was almost three years
ago that this was discovered players
continued to follow potential clues but
most seemed to lead to dead ends
the mystery was eventually left
abandoned and remains unsolved
most had probably forgotten about it i
know i had
then warlords of new york came along
followed closely behind by the manhunts
while chasing down jupiter one of her
audio collectibles had something
interesting to say
hey jupiter kind of busy
i know we found something kind of
strange
you're gonna have to be more specific
yeah there's like a room down here the
escape tunnel yeah i saw it
no not that
it's a room with
my guys and i were sterilizing burned
some altar looking things and we
accidentally opened this room you what
yeah it's like some kind of shrine or
something big-ass bird statue looks kind
of like an owl
the name morovian mean anything to you
i'll be right there
jupiter appears to know something about
the morivian society she almost sounds
concerned about it
as a quick recap on jupiter she was
recruited by the division eight years
ago after proving herself in the private
sector as a security consultant
leaning on a four-year military
background jupiter excelled in combat
and physical training exercises
she was noted as a potential risk due to
her past involvement in militant
activism a group that was later involved
with the kidnapping and assault of a
prominent business executive
nothing could ever be tied to her and
she claimed to have left the group by
the time of the incident
all psychological evaluations supported
her claims
perhaps her time as a security
consultant combined with the altercation
with this prominent business executive
has had her made aware of the secret
moravian society previously
maybe she knew what their goals were
[Music]
as we saw in her manhunt kina sent a
package of his own weaponized eclipse
virus
jupiter immediately disposed of the
package saying that the operation was
about getting rid of the green poison
not about spreading something that was
far more dangerous
jupiter we got a care package from kaner
a red package
yeah i saw it
what do you want me to do with it
get rid of it i don't want anything to
do with that you sure
you saw what it could do at city hall
this is the leverage keener was talking
about
this isn't some kind of silver bullet
saturn
it's a [ __ ] bio weapon
we're doing this to eradicate a virus
not spread something even more dangerous
of course
you're right
i'll destroy it
just be careful
i don't want to find out you dropped it
and killed the whole team
don't worry i've got this under control
yeah that's what they all say
until they don't
this is why she worked with the cleaners
they have a mutual interest in
eradicating the virus
for this reason i believe that she was
aware of what this merivian society is
capable of and based on her reaction it
will be something around the green
poison and how they could be using it as
a weapon
like i said earlier emeline shaw was
just a puppet perhaps a distraction
there could be something much larger at
play involving the outcasts and
orchestrated by the secret society
[Music]
perhaps there is more available to find
in regards to this mystery now that the
new york map has been opened up
it's clear the devs want us to keep
looking into it if it was just a simple
easter egg we wouldn't have had to jump
through so many hoops in order to access
it and there really hasn't been any
indication that what has been found so
far is the end of it
no collectibles no cosmetics just a
couple of lines that on their own don't
provide much
so why after all this time ever decided
to talk about this
i
actually don't know i was randomly
thinking about it one day and decided to
go back in there it felt like there was
something maybe we'd all missed
i guess part of the reason for releasing
this video is to revitalize the mystery
and get people talking about it
the amazing crew in the division ii
secrets discord have brought us this far
but there is still something missing
here too many questions left unanswered
so what do you think there are a number
of you far greater at solving these than
i and while i'm going to keep hunting
around for clues and leads that see me
around the map i'd love to hear what you
think
bohemian grove morovian society owls a
single book on the table dead rats
there are plenty of potential pieces to
work with here
if you want to check out the cave
yourself i'll have a link to the
original reddit post in the description
as well as the division 2 secrets
discord
anyway i'm going to dive back in
hopefully you'll have some ideas of
things that we may have missed up until
now thanks for watching and i'll catch
in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]